und wir bleiben im wald und da lässt
sich jemand blickenden kenne schon nur
allzu gut und der macht auch mal
probleme hier sehen sie es sozusagen
einen teuren hinterteil in die kamera ja
das ist eine wild hier falle die hat
diesen beweis jetzt geliefert der
problembär in bayern das zurück er ist
wieder da der bär zurück in bayern
diesmal in bad tölz wieder streift ein
bär durch die bayerischen wälder
verbreitet angst und schrecken bei
mensch und tier am wochenende tappt der
braunbär durch diese fotofalle gibt sich
zu erkennen
schon im mai bären alarm pünktlich zum
g7-gipfel dem treffen der mächtigsten
regierungschefs der welt schleicht ein
bär durch die wälder l maus kommt den
mächtigsten männern der welt ganz nah
und lässt bauern verzweifeln schafft
sich der christian euler entsetzt ist es
ungewöhnlich dass ein bär so viele so
viele in seiner art und weise tötet also
wir waren erschrocken entsetzt zurück
das wird mir die bilder gesehen habe
also einen tierfreund wird eine das herz
wenn er siegt ist der g7 bär nun zurück
handelt es sich gar um einen weiteren
bären noch ungewiss erst wenn code oder
haare des tieres gefunden werden können
diese brisanten fragen geklärt werden
allerdings die erneute bären sichtung
weckt erinnerungen an 2006 als ganz
deutschland über den problembären von
bayern diskutiert
dann haben wir normal verhalten er lebt
im wald gibt niemals auf
und reist vielleicht ein bis zwei
schafen ja
wir haben dann einen unterschied
zwischen den normalen sie falten wer die
hardware und dem problem werden da gibt
es nur die lösung ihn zu beseitigen weil
einfach die phase los ist und jetzt der
braunbär von bad tölz endet es ähnlich
dramatisch wie 2006 als problembär bruno
abgeschossen wird oder kommt das tier
mit heiler haut davon
und verschwindet schnell wieder von der
bildfläche
darüber sprechen wir mit unserem bild
reporter jörg völkerling jetzt der schon
vor dem g7 gipfel ja quasi auf der jagd
war auf der suche war nach diesem
problembären jetzt kann man hier im
studio sitzen und sagen ist ja eine
lustige geschichte aber das ist schon
ein problem für die menschen dort in bad
tölz im moment
ja in der tat die sehen das ganze gar
nicht locker und die sehen das auch
nicht so wie der bund naturschutz der
meint man müsse den bären willkommen
heißen in bayern für die almbauern ist
das ein fast existenzielles problem wir
waren ja ende mai mit dem bergbau und
christian noyer unterwegs der auch schon
2006 betroffen war von problembär bruno
und der uns einfach erzählte dass dieser
bär vor elektrozäunen ich halt macht vor
schluchten die auch hochklettert nicht
halt macht also alle schutzkonzepte
funktionieren nicht und was das brisante
ist es gab jetzt auch offenbar die erste
begegnung von einem menschen mit diesem
wären eine frau bei mittenwald am lauter
see also exakt diesen see diesem
campingplatz dem gerade in dem beitrag
gesehen haben ist dem br jetzt zum
ersten mal mit ihrem hund begegnet sie
hatten augenkontakt sichtkontakt sie war
wie paralysiert hat sie gesagt konnte
sich nicht bewegen der bär hat sich dann
von selber durchs unterholz davon
geschlichen und es wird also wirklich
von tag zu tag brennende dass die leute
sich auch vertraut machen mit den
verhaltensregeln die das landesamt für
umwelt in bayern erlassen hat wenn man
einen bären sang leise reden auf sich
aufmerksam machen ganz vorsichtig die
arme bewegen wenn es zu einem angriff
kommen sollte dann auf den boden legen
die hände in den nacken möglicherweise
ein rucksack der schutz bietet ein bär
würde sich in gruppen im normalfall im
prinzip nur nähern und schnuppern und
dann von einem ablassen aber naja der
normalfall bei einem bären der schon so
die scheu verloren hat ein menschliches
gebiet vorzudringen ich weiß nicht ob
das so wirklich ein trost ist für die
leute wo soll er denn eigentlich wieder
hin zurück dieser wer also jetzt hat man
so ein paar tipps und hofft natürlich
dass sie jetzt nicht noch mehr kommen
das sind ja eher einzelgänger diese
tiere aber wohin will man denn was
allein
na ja die frage ist weniger wo man ihn
gerne hätte sondern wo es den ähren
hintreibt sind offenbar männliche tiere
und es offenbar auch nicht nur ein
einzelner bär der in diesem grenzbereich
karwendel wetterstein jetzt bad tölz
unterwegs ist während die auf der
partnersuche sind nach weiblichen bären
und die offenbar aus einer
bärenpopulation im trentino stammen dort
gibt es 60 bären tendenz steigend die
alle auch offenbar so schimpfen auch die
bauern in bayern mit schaafs kadavern
gefüttert worden sind und damit erst
quasi so richtig scharf gemacht worden
sind auf die beute und es gab im juli
eine sichtung ausgerechnet auf dem
postweg bären bad in tirol und es gab
diese diesen riss ende mai bei scharnitz
auf der bär alte also man hat fast das
gefühl der bär ist da auf historischen
wanderpfaden unterwegs die auch
entsprechend deswegen nach insel benannt
sind also einhalt gebieten kann man ihm
nicht man kann es vielleicht mit markus
söder halten der am dienstag ist auf
eine almwanderung mit seiner landschafts
landwirtschaftsministerin unterwegs
waren zum thema wolf gesagt hat der
gehört hier nicht hin und auch darauf
vorbereitet hat dass man hier über
entnahme nachdenken muss und auch
möglicherweise die voraussetzung
schaffen muss bären die sich
menschlicher behausungen besiedlung
annähern auch schießen können muss danke
für deine information der problembär in
bayern ist zurück in und um bad tölz
jörg völkerling unser bild reporter
danke dir
[Musik]